pro-democracy protesters are back on the
streets in myanmar this morning despite
a u.n report
that at least 18 people were killed a
day earlier by forces loyal to the
military government
and just hours ago the country's top
civilian leader was charged with two new
offenses
raymiennocencio reports on the
demonstrations
pro-democracy protesters threw molotov
cocktails at police in yangon
myanmar's most populous city elsewhere
they put out smoking tear gas canisters
fired by security forces hundreds of
thousands of people on sunday
called for the military junta to free
aung san tsuchi
this was their answer this man along
with several
others shot dead in the southeast town
of daway
a bullet pierced through this man's back
and stomach
his lifeless body rushed into an
ambulance everyone
fighting for aung san sushi the 75 year
old nobel laureate finally appeared in
court monday via video conference
charged with two new violations inciting
public unrest
and violating communications laws her
lawyer told cbs news the charges
are political what do the military
leaders want
erase her from the political scene of
the country
do you have any fear that she might
spend the rest of her life
in prison she will be a martyr already
memorials and martyrs are starting to
rise where pro-democracy protesters fell
more funerals to fire up anger against
myanmar's military
that so many want buried instead
for cbs this morning raymie in ascencio
beijing